[Music]  hello  no you can't tell  baby  you want to come over and have a drink  [Applause]  [Music]  i don't know gamble we got the house  rules on the board over here it's best  two out of three  keep the action moving okay  stay safe out there looks like you're  fixing a run nah man we gotta make it  all right  id  that's a blockbuster card  i don't like getting hustled  and things that i don't like wind up in  a whole new desert i'm out here  you know i've been trying to track her  down for over a year she's important to  me man  see you're still playing music yeah yeah  still banging away you know it's been  really good to me okay that's amazing  you gotta take care  [Music]  you are so talented  it's always just a matter you pull it  together  once again you have no idea what you are  talking about  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  it's gonna be great  it'll be just like old times that's  scary  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you